necesitamos con más información aquí en
frases 24 y es tiempo de hablar de
economía estamos para eso con daniel
hablando nada ni la bienvenida y alabó
de la salida de eeuu de afganistán que
está dando de qué hablar en términos
económicos o la ley diana pues el retiro
de las tropas deja de eeuu con al menos
seis mil doscientos millones de dólares
en fondos no gastados para las extintas
fuerzas de seguridad afganas los fondos
incluyen 600 millones de dólares del año
fiscal 2020 aprobados pero no gastados
así como 2.300 millones de este año
hasta junio y otros 3 mil 300 millones
solicitados para el próximo año según la
agencia bloomberg ahora el departamento
de defensa deberá decidir junto al
congreso de eeuu a qué programa va a
destinar estos fondos lo cierto es que
retirarse también cuesta liliana y es
que el pentágono ya solicitó 5600
millones de dólares para el próximo año
dirigido a lo que denominaron guerra
directa en afganistán que bajo la
situación actual podría decirse que
equivale a la evacuación masiva que se
está realizando desde kabul
bueno daniela y en puerto rico- aprueban
un aumento salarial del salario mínimo y
usted nos va a contar los detalles si
liliana pues hoy en día el salario
básico de los puertorriqueños es de 725
dólares la hora un valor que rige desde
2009 y el senado de la isla ratificó dos
alzas automáticas que ya habían sido
aprobadas por la cámara de
representantes la primera desde el
primero de enero de 2022 el salario va a
ser de 8,5 dólares por hora y la otra en
julio de 2023 hasta llegar a 95 dólares
un tercer aumento llegaría en julio de
2000 24 hasta los 10,5 dólares esto
previo autorización de la comisión
evaluadora del salario mínimo se estima
que la medida va a tocar a unos 176 mil
empleados o poco más del 20 por ciento
de la fuerza laboral del estado libre
asociado de estados unidos aunque
algunos legisladores se mostraron
inconformes ya que hace 12 años que no
sube el salario pero si el costo de vida
sanidad y en brásil mejoren las cifras
de contrataciones pues sólo en julio de
este año y el género más de
316.000 empleos formales su segundo
mejor resultado este año y un 3 8%
superior a lo registrado en junio en los
primeros siete meses de este año brasil
generó un total de 18 millones de
empleos formales impulsado por cinco
sectores principalmente el de servicios
entre enero y julio de 2020 recordemos
ya habían perdido 1,1 millones de
puestos producto de la pandemia pero
pese a que el gobierno brasileño lo
muestra como un logro de recuperación
económica lo es pero la crisis de la
salud en ese país mantiene el desempleo
en niveles récord cercanos al 15 por
ciento y se calcula que hay más de 30
millones de personas trabajando en la
informalidad daniela y la grandes
tecnológicas invertirán en
ciberseguridad liliana al menos 30 mil
millones de dólares es el aporte que
dará en google y microsoft para
ciberseguridad en este país y es que la
quieren mejorar después de lo que pasó
hace unos meses con colonial pipeline la
red de oleoductos más grande de eeuu
hackeada por un grupo informático
llamado dark side tras una reunión del
presidente joe biden con los principales
líderes del sector privado y de la
educación en eeuu discutieron el impacto
de los ciberataques a grandes y pequeñas
empresas la casa blanca anunció que
google se comprometió a invertir 10 mil
millones de dólares y certificar a
100.000 estadounidenses en habilidades
digitales por su parte microsoft dijo
que aportará 20 mil millones de dólares
cuenta daniela cómo están parados los
indicadores wall street en cerró el
jueves con pérdidas con los
inversionistas muy atentos a la reunión
anual de banqueros centrales de este
viernes y con un anuncio liliana la
compañía forbes que es la editora de la
conocida revista que elabora el ranking
de los multimillonarios saldrá a bolsa
mediante una fusión con otra empresa
valorada en 630 millones de dólares en
europa la difusión de la variante delta
castigó a las principales bolsas que
cerraron en números rojos al tiempo que
esperan también el encuentro de jackson
julio y en américa latina las
principales bolsas se mantienen al agua
en hielo por la información de economía
y usted dirá si es por estar aquí en las
24 con televen con más entradas 24 punto
com